Homer Simpson isn't just a cartoon
character he is officially one of the
most influential people of the modern
era and he's also a pretty horrible
human being for over 30 years homers
been abusing his kids lying to his wife
and causing all kinds of mayhem as a
result hey we love the guy but the
citizens of Springfield probably lost
their affection for Homer Simpson long
ago especially after he did all these
things the Maude mishap Maude Flanders
demise via t-shirt cannon is arguably
the most shocking and callous end in the
Simpsons long and storied history and
alone again naturally the Flanders and
Simpsons families visit the local
racetrack and Homer becomes obsessed
with the cheerleaders t-shirt cannons
like really obsessed first he takes off
his own shirt trying to get the
cheerleaders attention next he paints a
bull's-eye on his chest given homers
size that would be an easy target and
the cheerleaders let a barrage of
t-shirts fly straight at him and then
and that's the end of the line for poor
Maude who didn't do anything wrong aside
from crossing paths with Homer Simpson
one too many times
celebrity send-off technically the
Simpsons annual treehouse of horror
episodes aren't canonical which gives
the show's writers plenty of room to
stretch their creative muscles and go
crazy but even by normal standards the
2009 treehouse of horror segments how to
get ahead in dead Verte icing is extra
creepy the episode begins as a Mad Men
parody but quickly descends into a dark
story in which Homer hunts down
superstars for money Homer starts by
accidentally pushing Krusty the Klown
into a wood chipper and then he accepts
money from advertising executives to
drown George Clooney in cement the
strangle prince with his own guitar and
to brain neil armstrong with a golf club
if only homers non-imaginary Adventures
weren't also totally nuts
framing Marge if you ask die-hard
Simpsons fans to recommend homers
overall lowest moment most of them will
probably point you to codependence day a
season 15 episode that chronicles
Marge's struggle with alcoholism Homer
of course has been a beer guzzling
boozehound since the very beginning
but in codependence day he enables
Marge's addiction first he takes her to
Moe's then they go to an Oktoberfest
celebrate
but the worst moment that comes when
Homer plastered from the beer festival
tries to drive home and ends up flipping
the car when the police arrive he frames
Marge who's even more drunk than he is
Marge goes to jail for driving under the
influence and later checks into a rehab
facility
Homer meanwhile doesn't face a single
consequence now that's Homer style of
justice Vegas vows as the saying goes
what happens in Vegas stays in Vegas
unless you're Homer Simpson in the
episode vive Ned Flanders
Homer takes Ned to Vegas for a night of
crazy fun when they wake up from their
booze-soaked all-nighter they're married
to their waitresses from the night
before
so they flee back to Springfield and
forget about their second wives for
about three seasons in brawl in the
family the two cocktail waitresses track
down their husbands after a judge
refuses to annul Homer's marriage to
Amber he takes matters into his own
hands and gets the woman drunk when
amber wakes up she's married to Homer's
dad horrified amber takes off for Vegas
as soon as possible it's a funny way to
turn the tables until you actually think
about it for like two seconds that's
pretty creepy Homer kidney failure in
the season 10 episode kidney trouble we
all learn a valuable lesson
Homer's an even bigger jerk than we
thought in the first half of the episode
Homer causes his dad AIDS kidneys to
explode because he doesn't want to stop
to let him use the bathroom the doctor
tells Abe he's a goner without a
transplant unfortunately Homer is an
exact match less fortunately well it's
home while Homer agrees to donate a
kidney he takes off just before the
surgery leaving his father alone and in
pain
Abe only gets the life-saving organ he
needs after Homer gets hit by a car and
knocked unconscious giving dr. Hibbert
time to steal homers kidney and complete
the procedure Homer the henchman Homer
Simpson has had many many jobs but he's
only been good at one unfortunately that
happened to be when he was working for
Hank Scorpio a straight-up supervillain
this is Homer we're talking about of
course and he doesn't ever actually
notice that Scorpio is really a criminal
mastermind he's too busy doing literally
anything else to realize that he's
helping Scorpio conquer the world I'm
having a little trouble with the gun
Oh jerks no he's walking over to small
businessman even worse Homer doesn't
notice that his family is absolutely
miserable in Scorpios compound until
it's too late
eventually he comes around and Scorpio
lets Homer return to Springfield but not
before Scorpios forces managed to
conquer the East Coast
good job Homer they couldn't have done
it without you neighborly wish homers
gone out of his way to make Flanders
life miserable plenty of times but what
he does in the season 3 episode when
Flanders failed might take the cake at a
backyard barbecue
Flanders announces that he's quitting
his job to open his own store the left
aureum so naturally Homer uses the power
of a wishbone to wish for Ned's business
to fail it works the left aureum goes
out of business Ned's house is
repossessed and the Flanders are forced
to move into their car sure Homer
eventually saves Ned from bankruptcy but
Ned never would have been in trouble in
the first place if Homer hadn't been
such a jerk for that's Homer for you and
when he should be speaking and she's
hidden with your care thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]